اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
موسكو تتهم كييف والدول الغربيه بالسعي
لاحداث تمرد مسلح في روسيا وتوريط الروس
بانشطه ارهابيه ومتطرفه
حول تايوان واوروبا تعارض استخدام القوه
لتغيير الاوضاع في الماضي
شارع اول يوم سوف يكون هنالك عمليه تبادل
الاسرى بين الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين
يبدا الخميس ويشمل عدن وصنعاء ومناطق
يمنيه اخرى
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
اتهم رئيس جهاز الامن الروسي الكسندر
بورتنيكو اتهم كلا من اوكرانيا والدول
الغربيه بمحاوله تحريض الروس على التخريب
والتمرد المسلح على خلفيه غزو اوكرانيا
مؤكدا ان اجهزه الامن الاوكرانيه اطلقت ما
قادتها الغربيين مع قادتها الغربيين حمله
ايديولوجيه وتجنيديه عدوانيه تستهدف فيها
الروس وخصوصا جيل الشباب وقال ان هذه
الحمله تهدف الى توريط الروس في انشطه
تخريبيه وارهابيه ومتطرفات في روسيا
على صعيد اخر نقل الصحيفه امريكيه عن
وثائق مسربه احتماليه سيطره روسيا على
اجواء اوكرانيا وبالتالي خساره اوكرانيا
لمعركه السماء وفقدان السيطره على اجوائها
ابتداء من منتصف الشهر الحالي وحتى مايو
المقبل
مسار الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه قد يتغير
شهر المقبل والسبب نقص المعدات الجويه
العسكريه عند قوه
ازمه اوكرانيه تلوح في الافق لكن من صالح
روسيا التي قد تحقق امكانيه الهيمنه على
سمايا اوكرانيا وفق صحيفه وولشي نقلا عن
وثائق امريكيه عسكريه مسربه تحدي كبير
تواجهه الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه لنفاذ
الذخيره والصواريخ المضاده للطائرات
وتحديدا الذخيره المصممه بالطريقه
السوفيتيه لانظمه الدفاع الجوي الخاصه بها
بحسب الوثائق السريه ستستنفذ اوكرانيا
بالكامل مخزونها من صواريخ بكر بحلول
منتصف ابريل والصواريخ ياس 300 بالاضافه
الى بطاريتي نيسانس وبطاريه واحده للدفاع
الجوي ايريستي بحلول مايو وفق الصحيفه اذا
تم نفاد المعدات العسكريه هذه ستصبح معظم
البنى التحتيه الحيويه لاوكرانيا الواقعه
خارجه منطقه كييف ومنطقتين اخريتين في
جنوب غرب اوكرانيا من دون غطاء للدفاع
الجوي بعده مواقع حساسه غير محميه يبلغ 40
بدلا من سته النتيجه المحتمله لازمه
الدفاع الجوي استنادا لاحدى الوثائق قد
يفقد الجيش الاوكراني قدرته على حشد قواته
البريه بالقرب من الخطوط الاماميه وشن
الهجوم المضاد المقرر في الاسابيع المقبله
واقع لن يغيره سوى وفاء الدول الغربيه
وواشنطن بوعدهم في تسليح كييف
الوثائق الامريكيه السريه المسربه انتشرت
عبر عده تطبيقات بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وعلى راسها تطبيق يسمى ديسكورد فيما فما
هو هذا التطبيق وكيف كان يستخدم عند
بدايته
تطبيق امريكي للدردشه بالكتابه والصوت
والفيديو ينشط عليه 150 مليون مستخدم
شهريا وتبلغ قيمته 14 مليار و700 مليون
دولار عمر المنصه ثمان سنوات وتحظى بشعبيه
كبيره بين الشباب ورواد العاب الفيديو
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تم تداولها على
المنصه بدايه مارس قبل ظهورها على مواقع
اخرى ديسكورد نعمل مع السلطات الامريكيه
فيما يتعلق بوثائق البينتاجون المسربه
كشفت وسائل اعلام حكوميه صينيه تواصل
التدريبات العسكريه حيث استمرت السفن
الحربيه الصينيه في تنفيذ مناوراتها في
المناطق المحيطه بتايوان
وياتي هذا تصريح رغم اعلان الصين في وقت
سابق انها انهى التدريبات استمرت لمده
ثلاثه ايام
المتحدث باسم المفوضيه الاوروبيه رفض اي
محاوله لاستخدام القوه في مضيق تايوان
دعونا دائما وسنواصل الدعوه لاحلال السلام
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان نعارض بشده
استخدام القوه للقيام باي محاوله احاديه
الجانب لتغيير الوضع الراهن في تايوان
هذا واوردت صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
السيناريوهات والخيارات التي يمكن ان
تنتهجها الصين في حال ارادت غزو الجاره
تايوان حيث سيكون الغزو اخطر الاحداث في
القرن 21 حسب وصفها
لن تطلق الصين غزوا مباشرا وعلى حين غره
اذ يحتاج الهجوم تجمعا يستغرق اسابيع امر
سيكون تحت مراه ومسمع اقمار التجسس
الغربيه
ستلجا الى الحصار الخيار الابطئ والخفي
ابتداء بمناورات عسكريه قد تطول لتتحول
الى حظر جوي وبحري تقيس من خلاله الصين رد
فعل العالم
ومدى استعدادها للمواجهه تدعي الصين ان
تايوان جزء من اراضيها وتتعهد باستعادتها
حتى وان لجات الى استخدام القوه لاخضاع
الجزيره المحكومه بنقاط ضعف تثير شهيه
بكين لغزوها
فالقوه الدفاعيه العظيمه للتايوان هي
موقعها الجغرافي كجزيره مفصوله عن البر
الرئيسي بمضيق عاصف يبلغ عرضه 100 ميل لكن
ذلك في الوقت نفسه نقطه ضعفها الكبير وعلى
عكس اوكرانيا التي لها حدود بريه طويله مع
خمس دول اوروبيه تعتمد تايوان على اعاده
الامداد واعاده التسلح في البحر والجو
واغلاق هذه الطرق سيكون بنفس اهميه الغزو
البرمائي تقول التوقعات ان السيناريو
الغزو الصيني ليس مهما بقدر ما سيكون من
الاهميه لتداعياته غزو قد يجتذب اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده ودول
النيت الاخرى وربما اكثر
اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه بدا عمليات تبادل
الاسرى والمعتقلين مع الحوثيين يوم الخميس
المقبل ولمده ثلاثه ايام واشار الفريق
الحكومي في المفاوضات الى ان عمليه تبادل
الاسرى ستشمل رحلات جويه بين العاصمه
صنعاء وعدا ومناطق اخرى في اليمن بالتنسيق
مع لجنه الدوريه للصليب الاحمر كما اكد ان
الاستعدادات اكتملت اليوم الاول وهو طبعا
كان المقرر في يوم عشره وتم تاجيل العمليه
الى ثلاثه ايام بسبب الاجراءات طبعا التي
اخذت وقتها نظرا العدد الكبير عدد الذين
سوف يتم مبادلتهم تم تاجيل العمليه الى
ثلاثه ايام اليوم الاول سوف يكون
بحسب ما اتفق عليه
يوم طبعا بعد غد يوم الخميس يوم 13 من هذا
الشهر اول يوم سوف يكون هنالك عمليه تبادل
بين صنعاء وعدن 250 عصير ومخ تطف
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
استنفار للهيئات الصحيه في بريطانيا مع
بدء عشرات الاف الاطباء اضرابا لمده اربعه
ايام احتجاجا على انخفاض قيمه الاجور
اهلا بكم من جديد شارع عشرات الالاف من
الاطباء البريطانيين في اضراب وصف
بالكارثي سيستمر لمده اربعه ايام يمتنع
خلاله الطاقم الطبيه عن المشاركه في نظام
رعايه الصحيه الممول من الدوله ووفق
الرابطه الطبيه البريطانيه فان الاطباء
خسروا 26% من قيمه اجورهم الفعليه منذ
العام 2008 ويطالبون بزياده هذه الاجور
بنسبه
35% هذا وحذر مسؤولون في هيئه الخدمات
الصحيه الوطنيه من شلل قد يصيب نظام
الرعايه الصحيه خاصه وان الاضراب سيتسبب
في تاجيل ما يصل الى 350 الف موعد مع طبيب
حيث قال ستبن بايوس المدير الصحي للنظام
العام في الهيئه ان التعبئه الجاريه ستخلف
اكبر تاثير في تاريخ الخدمات الصحيه
الوطنيه
وستولد الكثير من الضغوط وحينها ستكون
الاولويه للحالات الطارئه
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع ما من
لندى الان مراسل العربيه مصطفى زار ومصطفى
اهلا وسهلا بك في حال لم تستجب الحكومه
البريطانيه لمطالب الاطباء ما هي
السيناريوهات المتوقعه وانعكاس ذلك على
شعبيه حكومه ريشوسنا
مكتب رئيس الوزراء قال بان لن تكون هناك
اي مفاوضات ما لم
يتخلى الاطباء المضربون عن العمل عن
موقفهم مبدئي وهو رفع الاجور بنسبه 35%
وبالتالي سيكون هناك تصعيد وفي اخر المطاف
من يدفع الثمن وهو المواطن العادي الذي
بحاجه الى رعايه صحيه وان يلتقي مع طبيبه
او القيام بما يلزم من من عمليات جراحيه
يجب تذكير ايضا بان هناك الملايين من
مواعيد
المرضى الغي يعني في تاخير بسبب اولا
جائحه كورونا وبسبب الاضرابات المتتاليه
ما يمكن ان نفهمه من قبل نقابه اطباء
المضربين وانه سيتم تصعيد الموقف من خلال
تمديد فترات
الاضراب في الاشهر
مبدئيا سيكون فقط لاربعه ايام ولكن هناك
توقعات بان يزيد عدد ايام الاضطرابات ربما
ستمتد لاسابيع ما لم ترضخ الحكومه للجلوس
والتفاوض مع نقابه هؤلاء المضربين
وبالتالي
الموقف متجه الى مزيد من التصعيد يعني في
خلفيه الصوره ورائك يعني هذه التجمعات من
الاطباء المضربين ومن يؤيدوهم وكذلك
الكلمات نسمعها في خلفيه الشاشه
مصطفى هل الاضراب يشمل جميع الحالات
الطبيه حتى الطارئه ام لا في استثناءات
طيب وهل لدى حكومه ريشيسوناك بدائل يعني
الاطباء المضربين في لديها خطه بديله
لتعويض هذا النقص في الاطباء ام لا
اولا يعني هناك نقص في الاطباء اصلا في
المملكه المتحده وخاصه في انجلترا هناك ما
يقارب من ثمانيه الاف وظيفه شاغره الان
للاطباء وبالتالي هؤلاء الذين يضربون
الاطباء المضربون عن العمل لاربعه ايام
يرسلون رساله قويه الى الحكومه بان تسمع
الى مطالبهم خصوصا وان غلاء المعيشه يعني
بحاجه الى رفع الرواتب ايضا بالنسبه
لسياسه التقشف التي شهدناها على مدى 15
عاما ايضا ادت الى مطالبه هؤلاء بهذه
النسبه خمسه وثلاثين في المئه وبالتالي
يقولون بان ان لم ترضخ الحكومه ربما سيتجه
هؤلاء الى الهجره من المملكه المتحده في
هذا الوقت الصعب الذي هو بحاجه الى كوادر
طبيه مثلها المضربين يقولون بان رواتبهم
التي عاده ما تتراوح ما بين 30 الى 34 الف
جنيه استرليني غير كافيه هناك من اضطر الى
الاستعانه باهله لدفع مثلا الايجار او حتى
الاقتراض وبالتالي يعني المشاكل متعدده
ولكن هؤلاء الذين يطالبون برفع رواتبهم
يقولون بانهم بحاجه اليها وان الحكومه بدل
من شهدنا المشاهد التي عندما كان يخرج
الجميع مصطفى مصطفى باختصار باختصار وبشكل
سريع لو سمحت هل من مبادرات وسطات يقوم
بها طرف ثالث لايجاد حل ام لا لا وجود لاي
وسطات على الطاوله
هناك وسطات لمحاوله جمع الحكومه وايضا مع
نقابه المضرب ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه ليست
هناك اي بوادر انه سيتم عقده خلال الايام
القليله المقبله وبالتالي الاضراب سيستمر
حتى السبت في الساعه السابعه صباحا ومن ثم
سيتم عقد جلسات اخرى ما اذا سيتم تمديد
هذا الاضراب ليكون ربما اكثر من اربعه
ايام وربما سيكون كارثي بالنسبه لعامه
الناس في انجلترا بالتحديد
من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زاهر شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه مصطفى
يشهد مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
حركه تشغيليه مرتفعه مع بدء العشر الاواخر
من شهر رمضان المبارك حيث بلغ عدد الرحلات
القادمه والمغادره من والى المطار اكثر من
ثلاثه عشر الف رحله منذ مطلع شهر رمضان
وحتى اليوم وسط خطط تشغيليه وضعتها
السلطات في المطار تتضمن اجراءات الطوارئ
والتدخل السريع
معنى مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف اهلا وسهلا
بك جديد المشهد من عندك وهل من ارقام
اعلنت عنها السلطات عن عدد المعتمرين
الذين استقبلهم المطار حتى الساعه
نعم اهلا بك عدد المسافرين الذين وصلوا
حتى الان الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي في جده وهما ايضا يشمل ذلك
المغادرين ايضا اكثر من مليونين مسافر
وهذا العدد الكبير ربما يعتبر تاريخي في
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده الذي
افتتح في عام 2019 كما نعرف ان بعد عام
2019 كان هناك العديد من الاجراءات بسبب
جائحه كورونا والتي قللت اعداد الحجاج
والمعتمرين هذا التحدي الكبير الذي ايضا
سيبدا لدى هذا المطار الضخم بعد ايام
وخلال هذه الايام التي نشهدها الان في
العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان وتزايد اعداد
المعتمرين وقاصدي المسجد الحرام نحن الان
نتواجد في الصاله رقم واحد في مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي كما تشاهدون وهي واحده
من الصالات المخصصه لاستقبال المعتمرين
بكامل الطاقه بالاضافه الى صاله الحج
والعمره وايضا صاله اخرى الصاله الشماليه
هذه الصلاه تمتد على مساحه تصل الى مليون
و300 الف متر مربع
تستوعب بشكل يومي وعلى مدار الساعه 130
الف مسافر على مدار الساعه يدعم ذلك
العديد من الخدمات في مجال النقل مثل قطار
الحرمين سته عشر رحله من من جده الى مكه
وايضا سبع رحلات الى المدينه بالاضافه الى
خدمات النقل
الترددي التي تستمر بشكل دوري هنا ايضا
العديد من الاحصاءات التي تمت خلال
نعم بمجرد وصول المعتمر الى المطار في
مطار جده هنا اعتماد كبير على التقنيه
حقيقه الخيارات متاحه
للمعتمرين هنا في هذا المطر في وقت الثروه
يعمل نحو سته عشر الف موظف بخطه مسبقه من
اداره المطار يعملون على الارشاد
للمعتمرين والزوار يقدمون المعلومات
بمختلف اللغات ايضا وسائل التنقل
للمعتمرين متاحه وقاصدي المسجد
الحرام متاحه بكافه الاشكال عبر قطار
الحرمين سواء الى مكه المكرمه او المدينه
المنوره او عبر وسائل النقل الاخرى
الحافلات سيارات الاجره وغيرها شكرا جزيلا
لك نواف عزيز من مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي في جده شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المتابعه
في افغانستان قالت الامم المتحده ان
قرارها حركه طالبان منع النساء من العمل
معها في افغانستان يضعها امام خيار مروع
ازاء مواصله عملياتها في هذا البلد
واوضحت الامم المتحده في بيان لها اما
طالبان تضع الامم المتحده بين خيار البقاء
وتقديم المساعدات او احترام المعايير التي
ينبغي عليها الالتزام بها
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات